see and I I've seen that you've also
given your opinion on it you've made
several videos on it can you tell us uh
just you know what you feel about it and
what's going on with it what's your
opinion on the Hans Magnus situation
currently
yeah so I'm not gonna have anything
groundbreaking or brand new that
somebody hasn't heard before uh my my
opinion sort of Remains the Same uh as
far as as far as cheating in chess is
concerned from an online standpoint it's
been made significantly simpler because
there is no face-to-face interaction
there is a million different ways to
cheat like I once lost the chess game to
a treadmill at a hotel literally any
device can play better than a human at
this point my dog if he really tried
hard enough could probably be able to
cheat online right and it's it's it's
something that you do and there's like I
say there's adults watching this right
now who are maybe 12 1300. who are right
now still trying to like cheat in their
daily games or something like that it's
it's just so easy but uh doing it when
you're much younger is different than
doing it over the board at the most
elite chess events right this is like a
completely separate conversation we're
having and just watching all this stuff
unfold it's
it's weird Maurice was on a couple of
days ago and he said
all publicity is not necessarily good
publicity like there's that saying all
publicity is good publicity and yes it's
true millions of people are talking
about Chess right now and thinking about
Chess the same way they were when the
Queen's Gambit was going on they go oh
wow chess is just as that big huh you
guys right so on the one hand for
someone like myself who obviously is
incentivized by bringing in beginners to
the game of chess as well as other chess
YouTubers who would enjoy a new wave of
players coming in just because they
heard about the drama were biased okay
we can shape our opinion in some nice
way to the audience like oh it's not
good no it's great if you offer a
YouTube Creator a 50 audience increase
that's great okay right they're lying if
they say it's not great but if it's on
the heels of something like this
yeah yeah that's where it's you know
it's one of these ethical things right
and um I the the truth is
one person knows the truth right like at
the end of the day if there actually is
currently cheating going on over the
board and that's unfortunately the man
who is
I don't want to say it's necessarily a
Witch Hunt after him but he's had more
social media mentions in chess than
maybe Magnus has like one and a half
times as many and that's Hans Neiman and
the truth is like I've been on stream
and I've thought about this and I've
talked about this I don't even know what
I want to happen anymore do you feel
that way because we're in too deep like
We're In Too Deep either
either this is like going to be a
massive hindrance to uh to Magnus and
and kind of like the the process and the
way that this has been handled or I
don't know I mean how do you discover
even physical proof of cheating right so
there's nothing there's just nothing
there's no winning here anymore and I
don't know I'm apprehensively awaiting
the conclusion of all of this really
that's that's what that's really what it
is and it's but I'm not gonna sit here
and say oh it's so terrible because I
can't that would be lying right YouTube
creators and people who are actively
working in the online chess world we
want more eyes on chess so it's a tough
spot so that's my long statement but
that stuff